en sortant de mon école de commerce
j'étais programmé pour vendre des
lessives et très vite j'ai arrêté parce
que moi ce que je voulais c'était être
utile à la société l'accompagner dans
ses changements
alors j'ai choisi de rentrer à et tous
mes copains m'ont dit que j'étais folle
mais en fait ça fait 24 ans que je suis
dans cette entreprise
j'en suis une des dirigeantes et je
dirige à un territoire où travaillent
près de 3000 personnes et il ya un peu
plus d'un an
j'étais à la fenêtre de mon bureau je
regardais les voies et il n'y avait pas
de train mais à côté sur la route les
voitures s'entassent et et là je me suis
dit il est vraiment temps de faire
bouger les lignes
et c'est pour ça que je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est pour nous c'est pour
vous alors pour venir ici aujourd'hui à
la rochelle
eh bien j'ai pris ma voiture parce que
il n'y a pas de trains qui arrivent à 20
heures alors je sais un certain nombre
d'entre vous vont dire balles d'ak en
ajouter une un malines puisque tu en as
le pouvoir
ouais mais malheureusement ce n'est pas
parce qu'on ajoute un train qui sera
rempli et s'il n'est pas rempli il va
nous coûter
il va vous coûter et surtout il ne
remplira pas sa fonction sociale et
sociétale donc en vérité je n'ai pas eu
le choix de mon moyen de transport j'ai
dû choisir un moyen de transport paulhan
parce que oui ma voiture n'est pas
électrique
et quand bien même elle l'aurait été
elle n'aurait vraisemblablement pas eu
l'autonomie pour pouvoir faire le chemin
d'une seule traite
j'aurais été obligé de m'arrêter pour la
recharger et
j'aurais été en retard à notre rendez
vous parce que je n'ai pas les moyens de
me payer la seule voiture qui a une
autonomie très longue et qui commence
par acheter mais pire que tout je sais
que si je ne change pas ma façon de
voyager alors dans 100 ans c'est bientôt
un pour les plus anciens disent dans la
salle
c'est la génération de vos petits
enfants et j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
enfants dans la salle ce seront vos
propres enfants qui verront que la
rochelle sera sous les eaux vous et moi
nous en aurons été responsable car nos
transports représentent 32% des
émissions de co2 en france
bon mais dans son temps est ce qu'on
sera plus ou moins que maintenant parce
que après tout il ya des représentations
3d il ya des lunettes virtuel on a des
téléconférences des visioconférences on
à skype
bon alors plus besoin de se déplacer
mais en fait non parce qu'il ya une
règle qui est simple et ce depuis
l'invention du télégraphe plus on
communique plus on voyage au début du
20e siècle
tous les jours on parcourait 125 mille
fois le tour de la planète
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 4 millions de
fois que nous faisons le tour de la
terre tous les jours pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur c'est la distance
entre la terre et le soleil plus de
mille fois donc avec l'accroissement des
télécommunications nous allons continuer
à voyager toujours plus et forcément
nous allons avoir à faire face à
plusieurs enjeux
le premier on l'a vu c'est la pollution
mais le deuxième c'est les coûts que
diriez vous si un jour vous deviez
choisir entre manger et vous déplacer
parce que votre budget n'est pas
extensible
le troisième ça sera le temps parce que
si on voyage plus comment ne pas perdre
son temps dans les transports
alors passez à sa bonne nouvelle les
transports sont en train d'évoluer et je
devrais dire c'est sur les rails ou
presque façon de parler c'est le cas par
exemple du projet hyper look qui est en
passe de devenir une réalité en 2016 à
san francisco un train circulant à 1200
km heure dans un tube vide d'air devrait
être testé super une vraie prouesse
technologique le digne fils de tgv mais
en beaucoup plus vite
mais enfin vous vous êtes posé la
question de savoir pourquoi alors que ça
fait plus de trente ans qu'on a inventé
le tgv il n'était pas présent sur toute
la planète
alors qu'il nous faisait gagner du temps
c'est pas parce qu'on est des mauvais
vendeurs c'est tout simplement pour des
questions de coût de coûts de ces
infrastructures nouvelles qui se compte
en milliards et le projet hyper loupe va
avoir à affronter aussi ses freins
structurels qui va sans doute bloquer
son développement à grande échelle
rapidement qui plus est le projet actuel
ne permet d'emporter que 800 voyageurs à
l'heure globalement c'est la capacité
d'emport d'un tgv alors pour accroître
la croissance du trafic
ben ça va être un peu juste bon mais
alors pour les transports individuels et
bien ya la voiture électrique et on sait
tous que son autonomie augmentée mieux
encore la voiture à hydrogène plus de
1000 km d'autonomie en 2025
on parle des premières
commercialisations ces voitures elles
vont se conduire tout seul ça y est on
l'a notre solution pas en fait pas tout
à fait et pour cette raison la place
la place que prennent deux cents
passagers dans des véhicules en moyenne
une voiture c'est un de passagers à bord
si on les met dans des bus ça donne ça
et dans des trains efficace non pour
pouvoir accompagner la croissance des
transports oui la croissance de notre
mobilité passera sans doute par
davantage de transports en commun mais
les simples ruptures technologiques ne
sont pas suffisantes pour faire face aux
trois enjeux que je vous ai cités tout à
l'heure et pour une raison qui est
simple et bien ce n'est pas en
améliorant la bougie qu'on a inventé
l'électricité alors comment est ce qu'on
peut penser ses moyens du futur avec ce
qu'on a parce que on n'aura pas beaucoup
de capacités d'investissement et bien ça
va nous demander sans doute non pas de
la science fiction mais de rêver parce
que dans chaque rêve
il y a une part de réalité et puis aussi
un peu d'ouverture d'esprit
parce que si je vous avais dit à vous il
ya vingt ans que dans votre poche vous
auriez une chaîne hi-fi l'encyclopédie
universalis un appareil photo une lampe
de poche pourquoi pas et votre appareil
photo
vous m'auriez dit quoi et pourtant on
est nombreux à l'avoir c'est le
smartphone et oui il y a beaucoup
d'intérêt à rapprocher des choses que
jusqu'à présent on se séparait et bien
moi je vous propose qu'à l'instar de ce
qui a été fait pour le smartphone on
fasse pour les transports la smart
mobility
c'est quoi le meilleur des transports
guidés le meilleur de l'automobile est
le meilleur des transports en commun je
sais ça doit vous apparaître un peu flou
mais comme on aime bien les acronymes
après le tgv je vous propose qu'on
appelle le tac
et que l'on regarde en images ce que ça
pourrait donner pour chacun d'entre nous
imaginons en toi il habite en ville et
souhaite partir en week-end à la
campagne ils commandent taki sur son
smartphone
antoine ne va pas à l'arrêt du tac c'est
à qui viennent jusqu'à antoine
avec ses valises ils montent à bord et
découvre d'autres passagers qui vont
dans la même direction mais ne seront
pas tous à la même destination
tac est un véhicule autonome électrique
qui peut rouler aussi bien sur la route
que sur les rails pour entrer sur les
voies il emprunte les passages à niveau
une fois sur les rails il se recharge
tac peut modifier sa route en fonction
des encombrements des réseaux ferrés ou
outils
les passagers échanges tac où ils
veulent plus besoin de gars pour passer
du tac au tac
antoine a bien profité de son temps à
boire maintenant tac le dépose à sa
maison de campagne mais pas de repos par
tak tak toujours merci je suis contente
que ça vous plaise mais on va se le dire
technologiquement on n'y est pas encore
tout à fait pour autant c'est pas très
difficile parce que toutes les briques
technologiques existent et il nous faut
aujourd'hui les assembler pour arriver à
construire tac par exemple en france il
existe plus de quinze mille passages à
niveau qui sont aujourd'hui des lieux
très accidentogène et qui demain
pourraient devenir des lieux de
croisement autant de portes d'entrée et
de sortie entre les différents réseaux
de même il existe des systèmes qui
permettent de réguler l'éloignement
entre deux mobiles en mouvement et qui
permettrait par exemple que sur un même
réseau cohabitent des trains et des tac
non en fait technologiquement ce que
nous avons vraiment à faire c'est de
réinventer la roue et je ne sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais à chaque grande
évolution en matière de transport et
bien il y a eu une roue nouvelle qui a
été inventé en pierre ou en bois en
acier en pneumatiques il est sans doute
temps d'inventer la roue du 21e siècle
ça prendra peut-être dix ans mais tout à
fait réalisable en fait ce que nous
aurons à changer le plus c'est nous
mêmes parce que notre moyen de transport
individuel
on le lem c'est quelque part notre droit
à aller où on veut quand on veut comme
on veut c'est un peu de notre liberté
votre coin à champignons par exemple
vous avez pas envie d'y aller en attaque
je vous rassure demain vous n'irez pas
en attaque non plus pourquoi parce que
pour que des transports en commun soit
efficace il faut un minimum de flux même
si les personnes ne vont pas à la même
destination
et si avec tak on peut descendre des
transports en commun sur des flux plus
petit pour votre coin un champignon qui
je l'espère n'est pas connu par grand
monde
eh bien le véhicule individuel sera
toujours le plus efficace en fait moi ce
que je vous propose c'est qu'on
réinvente et transports en commun des
transports en commun qui s'adapte à vous
à vos horaires parce que tous les jours
vous ne permet pas la porte à la même
heure de votre domicile des transports
qui viennent vous chercher là où vous
êtes
et c'est sans doute à cette condition
qu'on permettra que les transports en
commun qui représente aujourd'hui
seulement 15% de notre mobilité passe
sans doute à 30 % en 2030 et pourquoi
pas rêvons à 50% en 2050
alors aujourd'hui tac c'est un rêve il y
en ad'autres 1 qui rêvent l'école
polytechnique de lausanne rêve même à un
avion qui deviendrait un train est bien
moins je suis très fier de vous dire
qu'en 2000 on va avancer sur le sujet et
ça commence aujourd'hui nous allons vous
inviter à venir co construire avec nous
votre transport tac du futur qui
répondent à vos besoins vos exigences en
matière de mobilité sur le site facebook
vous trouverez le lien sur le twitter du
tedx la rochelle
et puis ça nous permettra ensemble de
travailler il n'y a pas de limite à
votre imagination
simplement on a besoin de vous pour
construire ce nouveau mode plus souple
plus respectueux de l'environnement qui
répondent aux
et à votre budget et il ya une chose que
je voulais vous dire tac en polonais ça
veut dire oui et tac en suédois et en
danois
ça veut dire merci